the Health and Human Services Secretary
that's Tom price this morning appears to
be fighting for his job right now he's
under fire for his expensive
taxpayer-funded travel abroad government
and private charter jets the trips by
interior secretary Ryan's inky EPA
Administrator Scott Pruett and Treasury
secretary Steve minuchin have also drawn
some criticism major Garrett is at the
White House with this growing political
problem for the Trump administration
major good morning good morning in his
inaugural address President Trump
described Washington as a place where
government officials enjoy benefits
unavailable to average Americans and
often coming at their expense bowing
those days were over now questions about
that exact conduct are being raised
about the president's own cabinet chief
Lee Health and Human Services Secretary
Tom Price all of the the trips as I
mentioned had been approved secretary
Price suggested its president Trump's
agenda that forced him to take ten trips
on private charters we have a very
ambitious agenda and we were trying our
doggonedest
to be able to accomplish the mission
price announced Thursday that he would
write a personal check to the US
Treasury for nearly 52,000 taxpayer
dollars it cost for his seat and that
taxpayers won't pay a dime for my seat
on those planes but according to
Politico his actual bill to taxpayers
may be more than 1 million dollars after
it was revealed he used military
aircraft for trips overseas the
president has made it clear he is not
pleased I am not happy
[Music]
on Thursday White House press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders was asked if
prices job was safe so we're gonna
conduct a full review and we'll see what
happened the White House is conducting a
cabinet wide review of private air
travel the latest member under fire is
interior secretary Ryan Zinke according
to the Washington Post he spent more
than 12 thousand dollars of taxpayer
money on a private charter from Las
Vegas to his hometown in Montana
while EPA Administrator Scott Pruett has
spent nearly sixty thousand dollars on
non commercial flights Treasury
secretary Steve minutia also frequently
used expensive government and military
planes meanwhile the White House
counsel's office has launched a separate
internal review of the use of private
email accounts by top White House
officials past and present those under
scrutiny Jared Kushner Ivanka Trump Gary
Cohn still in the White House and Steve
Benin and Reince Priebus who have
recently left the building
Charlie major thanks